This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This show would not be possible without our advertisers. Seriously, don't worry, I'm not about to read some ads right now. I just want you to consider the way we use advertising. A lot of podcasters and radio hosts, myself included, read out messages from our sponsors, rather than play pre-recorded commercials. Rush Limbaugh does it?
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。如果没有广告商的支持，这个节目是无法制作的。说真的，别担心，我不是现在就要读什么广告。我只是想让大家思考一下我们使用广告的方式。很多播客和电台主持人，包括我自己，都是直接读赞助商的信息，而不是播放预先录好的商业广告。拉什·林堡（Rush Limbaugh）就是这样做的？
Bowl and Branch, they have re-invited sheets and bedding from our sponsors rather than play pre-recorded commercials. Rush Limbaugh does it? Bowl and Branch, they have re-invited sheets and bedding with the sole purpose of making your nighttime rest more comfortable than ever. Howard Stern does it? It's snore-stop extinguisher. Yes, the fast-acting snore spray. And these ads in some ways actually
Bowl and Branch，他们重新发明了赞助商的床单和寝具，而不是播放预先录好的商业广告。拉什·林堡就是这样做的？Bowl and Branch，他们重新发明了床单和寝具，唯一的目的就是让你的夜间休息比以往任何时候都更加舒适。霍华德·斯特恩（Howard Stern）就是这样做的？这是“止鼾灭火器”。是的，那款见效快的止鼾喷雾。从某种程度上讲，这些广告其实
harken back to where audio advertising began. But the journey of how we got to now is fascinating. The organist, a podcast from KCRW and McSweeney's, recently featured a two-part documentary about the surprising and strange history of radio advertising as heard to the years of Clive Desmond, a radio producer and podcast host who has worked extensively in the ad industry. His account of the evolution of ad spots, jingles, and voiceovers all add up into a story of his own journey. And it starts when he was a boy.
让人回想起音频广告起源的地方。但我们走到今天这一步的过程却十分迷人。KCRW和《麦克斯维尼》（McSweeney's）合作的播客节目《管风琴师》（The Organist）最近播出了一个两部分构成的纪录片，讲述了电台广告令人惊叹而又奇异的历史。这些历史是通过克莱夫·德斯蒙德（Clive Desmond）的耳朵呈现出来的，他是一位曾在广告行业广泛工作的电台制作人和播客主持人。他关于广告插播、商业歌曲（jingle）和画外音演变的叙述，汇聚成了一个关于他自己人生旅程的故事。而这一切，要从他还是个小男孩的时候说起。
I grew up in a little bungalow style house in Buffalo, New York. There was a beautiful radio in the kitchen. It was always on. In 1959, when I was two and a half, I began listening. My favorite station was WKBW. WKBW, but the law! It was a top 40 station.
我在纽约州布法罗的一个小简易别墅风格的房子里长大。厨房里有一台漂亮的收音机。它总是开着。1959年，当我两岁半的时候，我开始收听。我最喜欢的电台是WKBW。WKBW，但法律规定！这是一个播放排行榜前40名歌曲的电台。
So there were three or four commercials between every song. My advice says Susie. You like this brand new kind of leather, so be Susie. Listening as intensely as I did, I seem discovered that all radio commercials weren't the same. They were like pasta. They came in different shapes. There were monologue commercials, dialogue commercials, interview commercials,
所以每首歌之间都有三到四个商业广告。苏西说这是我的建议。你喜欢这种崭新的皮革，所以做苏西吧。由于我听得十分专注，我很快发现并不是所有的电台广告都是一样的。它们就像意大利面。它们有不同的形状。有独白式广告、对话式广告、访谈式广告、
musical commercials. But even to my tiny tender ears, I noticed all commercials had one thing in common, a certain lack of authenticity. The radio voices spoke with a cheery, make-believe tone, one that said, It's going to be wonderful. Everything's great. This was a tone I had never heard real people speak in, except for one of our neighbors, Mrs. Cunningham. She was an optimist. But then one day, when I least expected, I heard a radio commercial that featured a little girl. Marsha, what's your opinion of all the vitamins
音乐式广告。但即使在我幼小稚嫩的耳朵里，我也注意到所有的广告都有一个共同点，那就是某种程度的缺乏真实感。电台里的声音带着一种欢快、虚构的语气，那种语气仿佛在说：一切都会好起来的。一切都棒极了。这是我从未听过现实生活中的人会使用的语气，除了我们的一个邻居，坎宁安太太。她是个乐观主义者。但就在有一天，在我最意想不到的时候，我听到了一个以一个小女孩为主角的电台广告。玛莎，你对所有的维生素
and minerals in Bosco? I never saw them. You can't see them, but they're there. It says so right there on the label. I don't know how to read yet. I'm only four. Well, I'm sorry, Marsha. That's okay.
和波斯科（Bosco）里的矿物质有什么看法？我从来没见过它们。你看不到它们，但它们就在那里。标签上写得清清楚楚。我还不会读书呢。我只有四岁。好吧，对不起，玛莎。没关系。
Anyway, I don't care about finding things. I just like basketball, because it makes my mouth taste so good. What does it taste like? Like milk with chocolate in it. I don't think we'll forgot it. Well, Bosco's good for you. I know. But other things I like, Bosco contains vitamins.
不管怎样，我不在乎找东西。我只喜欢巧克力味，因为它让我的嘴里感觉太好了。它尝起来是什么味道的？就像加了巧克力的牛奶。我想我们不会忘的。嗯，波斯科对你有好处。我知道。但我喜欢的其他东西，波斯科含有维生素。
But I just like the taste good. Looks like you fooled her. But they're so smart. But they're smarter. This little girl's voice had a powerful effect on me, because she sounded as real as the girl who lived in the bungalow next door to us. A few days later, sitting in the back seat of the family car, we drove past WKBW in downtown Buffalo. I peered out the window at the station and wondered if the Bosco Surrup Girl lived there.
但我只是喜欢它好喝的味道。看来你被她骗了。但他们太聪明了。但他们更聪明。这个小女孩的声音对我有很强的吸引力，因为她听起来就像住在我们隔壁简易别墅里的那个女孩一样真实。几天后，坐在家里的汽车后座上，我们开车路过了位于布法罗市中心的WKBW。我透过车窗向电台张望，心想那个波斯科糖浆女孩是不是就住在那里。
I mean, how else could the girl in the commercial be on the radio like that all the time? I hadn't yet learned about the wonders of the tape recorder. While I sat in the car, pondering the whereabouts of the Bosco Surrup girl, 375 miles to the south in New York City, was the man who made the Bosco Surrup radio commercial. His name was Tony Schwartz. He was a radio producer and audio archivist. Tony Schwartz specialized in recording commercials with real people, instead of recording actors,
我是说，商业广告里的女孩怎么可能一直那样在电台里出现呢。我当时还不知道录音机的奇妙之处。当我坐在车里，琢磨着波斯科糖浆女孩的下落时，在正南方375英里的纽约市，住着制作这个波斯科糖浆电台广告的人。他的名字叫托尼·施瓦茨（Tony Schwartz）。他是一位电台制作人和音频档案管理员。托尼·施瓦茨专门用真人来录制广告，而不是录制那些
trying to portray real people, which meant the Bosco syrup girl was a real child and not a 35 year old actor playing a child. Schwartz's production philosophy was to avoid the use of any music or unnecessary sound effects. And when he did work with actors, Schwarze directed them not to sound like actors. In this way, Tony Schwarze was radio advertising's first modernist. A fire breaks out on the first floor of the two family house. Door. The woman quickly leaves to call the fire department. Door. And two people die upstairs.
试图扮演真实人物的演员，这意味着波斯科糖浆女孩是一个真正的孩子，而不是一个扮演孩子的35岁演员。施瓦茨的制作哲学是避免使用任何音乐或不必要的音效。当他与演员合作时，施瓦茨会指导他们听起来不像演员。从这个意义上说，托尼·施瓦茨是电台广告的第一位现代主义者。一栋双拼房的一楼突然发生火灾。门。这位女士急忙离开去打电话给消防部门。门。楼上有两个人死了。
Overcome by smoke. Door. A man smoking in bed starts a fire. The door. Leaves the bedroom, rushes to a foam. The door. And before the fire department gets there. The door.
被浓烟熏倒。门。一个在床上抽烟的男人引发了一场火灾。门。离开卧室，冲去打电话。门。在消防部门赶到之前。门。
The rest of his house burns down. The door. Is there one single act that could have been done? Close the door. The rest of his house burns down. The door. Is there one single act that could have been docked? To help prevent this needless loss of life and property. Close the door. What should these people have done? Close the door. Do you know that a door is one of the best pieces of fire fighting and life saving a quick-low's the door? And if you leave a room that is on fire,
他房子的其余部分被烧毁了。门。有没有哪一个单一的动作是可以完成的？关上门。他房子的其余部分被烧毁了。门。有没有哪一个单一的动作是可以做出的？为了帮助防止这种不必要的生命和财产损失。关上门。这些人本该做什么？关上门。你知道门是最好的灭火和救生工具之一吗？随手关上门！如果你离开一个着火的房间，
close the door. If you simply close the door, the door. It will help stop the fire and smoke from spreading too quickly. Close the door. This life-saving information is brought to you by this station and the New York City Fire Department. After I turned nine, every summer I was richly shipped to California to spend time with my cousins in San Francisco. Like most children, I was fond of Saturday morning cartoons. The more cartoons I watched, the more familiar I became with the characters, and the more
关上门。如果你简单地关上门，门。它将有助于阻止火灾和浓烟迅速蔓延。关上门。这条救生信息由本台和纽约市消防局为您提供。在我九岁之后，每年夏天我都会被“富有异国情调”地运送到加利福尼亚，去和我在旧金山的表亲们待在一起。像大多数孩子一样，我喜欢星期六早上的动画片。我看越多的动画片，我对角色就越熟悉，而且越
familiar I became with the characters, bugs the more familiar I became with the characters, Bugs, Bup-I, Bullwinkle. The more I took notice of their specific voices. But there was one voice I liked most, perhaps because he sounded so uncartoon-like. You may know him as Pete Booma, Jr. Bear, or Chimney Lamox. He appeared in Sylvester and Tweety, a bug's bunny road runner-hour, Renan Stimpy, Stuart Little, and I go Pogo, among hundreds of other shows. But when I was a boy, he was in radio commercials too. His name was Stan Freberg. Allowance in 1966, Chongqing.
熟悉角色，兔——巴斯，布普-I，布鲁温克尔。我就越注意到他们各自独特的声音。但有一个声音是我最喜欢的，也许是因为听起来一点也不像动画片里的声音。你可能知道他是小皮特·布马（Pete Booma, Jr. Bear）或奇尼·拉莫克斯（Chimney Lamox）。他曾出现在《西尔维斯特和崔弟》、兔八哥道路奔跑者小时秀、《莱恩和史丁比》、《小鼠斯图尔特》以及《波戈》（I go Pogo）等数百个其他节目中。但当我还是个小男孩的时候，他也出现在电台广告里。他的名字叫斯坦·弗雷伯格（Stan Freberg）。1966年，重庆牌杂碎（Chongqing）。
Sleek, American. A different breed of Chow-Man. You see it instantly in its old new bean sprouts. It's crisp, aggressive, water chestnuts. Talk about extras. You want bucket bamboo shoots. Power onions. You got it, Mr. In the 1966 Chun-King Chao main.
流畅的美国货。不同品种的炒面。你一眼就能从它全新的豆芽中看出这一点。它那爽脆、激进的水栗。说到额外料。你想要一桶竹笋。强力洋葱。你得到了，先生。1966年的重庆炒面。
Outside too, you'll notice the revolutionary styling of its round cans right away. Wrap around labels. More pick up in the two cans taped together. That standard equipment on this, baby. Look at the way she handles. In the bottom can, independent vegetable suspension. And in the top can, where the action is, over 27 cubic inches of succulent chunking sauce loaded with high performance chicken.
在外面，你也会立刻注意到它圆罐的革命性造型。环形标签。两个用胶带粘在一起的罐子更容易拿取。这可是这款宝贝的标准配置。看看它的操控方式。底部的罐子里有独立的蔬菜悬挂系统。而在顶部的罐子里，也就是好戏上演的地方，有超过27立方英寸的美味重庆酱汁，里面塞满了高性能的鸡肉。
Step up to the tuned Chao main, the 1966 chunking. Noodles optional. I didn't know who Stan Friedberg was, or how big a role he would play in the evolution of sound for radio commercials. But whenever I heard his voice, it got my attention. One night, driving over the Golden Gate Bridge with my uncle Owen, Stan Freiburg's voice
向这款经过调校的炒面迈进，1966年的重庆面。面条可选。我不知道斯坦·弗雷伯格是谁，也不知道他在电台广告声音的演变中会扮演多么重要的角色。但每当我听到他的声音，它就会吸引我的注意力。一天晚上，和欧文叔叔一起开车过金门大桥时，斯坦·弗雷伯格的声音
popped out of the speaker. Stand, I ask my uncle. Could you turn that up? Radio, why should I advertise on radio? There's nothing to look at, no pictures. Listen, you can do things on radio, you couldn't possibly do on TV. That'll be the day. All right, watch this. OK, people, and now when I give it a cue,
从扬声器里传了出来。斯坦，我问叔叔。你能把声音调大点吗？电台，我为什么要投电台广告？又没有东西可看，没有画面。听着，你能在电台里做一些在电视上绝对做不到的事情。有那么一天吧。好吧，看着。好了，各位，现在当我给出暗号时，
I want the 700 foot mountain of whipped cream to roll into Lake Michigan, which has been drained and filled with hot chocolate Then the Royal Canadian Air Force will fly overhead toying a ten ton Marasino cherry Which will be dropped into the whipped cream to the cheering of 25,000 extras. All right. Shoot them out You're the Air Force You the Marish, you don't charry. Okay, 25,000 cheering extra. Now, you want to try that on television?
我要让那座700英尺高的鲜奶油山滚进密歇根湖，密歇根湖已经被抽干并注满了热巧克力。然后加拿大皇家空军将从头顶飞过，拖着一颗十吨重的玛拉斯奇诺樱桃，它将被投进鲜奶油中，伴随着25,000名群众演员的欢呼。好了。把它们射出去！你们是空军！你们是玛拉斯奇诺樱桃！好的，25,000名欢呼的群众演员。现在，你想在电视上试试这个吗？
Well... You see, radio is a very special medium because it stretches the imagination. Doesn't television stretch the imagination? Up to 21 inches, yes. Poo listens to radio, was part of an advocacy campaign sponsored by the radio advertising bureau of America, to encourage clients to buy more radio time. Apparently, radio was going through a sales drought.
嗯……你看，电台是一个非常特殊的媒介，因为它能拓展想象力。难道电视不能拓展想象力吗？最多21英寸吧。谁听电台啊？这是美国电台广告局（Radio Advertising Bureau of America）赞助的一场宣传活动的一部分，旨在鼓励客户购买更多的电台广告时间。显然，电台当时正经历销售低谷。
Nevertheless, Stan Freberg was the main voice of this epic radio commercial, and that's what caught my attention. Hearing Freiberg command a 700-foot mountain of whipped cream being rolled into Lake Michigan, while the Royal Canadian Air Force towed a giant maraschino through the sky. It flipped a switch in my imagination, as nothing had before. This was bigger than the Bosco chocolate syrup roll, although in hindsight, she was still pretty good. Two and nine-year-old, two weeks, bills like a year. And that was more than enough time for me to untether myself from the familiar sounds of Buffalo, and absorb the subtly different tone and tempo of California.
尽管如此，斯坦·弗雷伯格仍然是这个史诗般电台广告的主音，正是这一点吸引了我的注意力。听到弗雷伯格指挥一座700英尺高的鲜奶油山滚进密歇根湖，而加拿大皇家空军在空中拖着一颗巨大的玛拉斯奇诺樱桃。它拨动了我想象力中的开关，这是以前任何东西都无法比拟的。这比波斯科巧克力糖浆广告更震撼，尽管事后看来，那个广告依然相当不错。两个9岁的小孩，两周时间，感觉像过了一年。这已经有足够的时间让我从布法罗熟悉的SOUND中解脱出来，去吸收加州微妙不同的音调和节奏。
California. Hmm. Two weeks on the west coast that cleared my mind mind and ready me for the next phase in my radio commercial journey. After my vacation ended, I was sent home to Buffalo via the scenic route. I spent most of my time in the observation car with the new transistor radio my uncle Owen had given me as a going away present. The radio, model name Juliet, was about the size of an iPhone 5. It was an inch deep and came with a leather cover as soft as a lambs ear. But of most importance, it had an earplug. The earplug looked like a piece of outmoded technology from the Balkan wars, brown and
加利福尼亚。嗯。在西海岸的两周清醒了我的头脑，为我电台广告之旅的下一阶段做好了准备。假期结束后，我坐着观光路线的火车被送回了布法罗。我大部分时间都待在观景车厢里，手里拿着欧文叔叔送给我的临别礼物——一台崭新的晶体管收音机。这台收音机型号叫朱丽叶（Juliet），大约有iPhone 5那么大。它有一英寸厚，还配有一个像小羊耳朵一样柔软的皮革套。但最重要的是，它有一个耳机插孔。这个耳机插孔看起来像是巴尔干战争时期的过时技术，像核桃一样又棕又圆，通过一根卷曲的电线连在收音机上。用耳机收听对我来说是一种全新的体验。就像待在一个收音机作茧自缚的蚕茧里一样。一个又一个电台，一个又一个广告，我开始慢慢过量接收。然后我发现了一个令人不安的事实。我听得越多，就越能认出所有电台和广告的千篇一律。在这个回音室里呆了几个小时后，我感到厌倦了。我想听点新的或不同的东西。两天后，穿过美国心脏地带后，火车在芝加哥停留了一个小时。
round as a walnut attached to the radio by a coiled wire. Listening with the earplug was a new experience for me. It was like being in a radio cocoon. Station after station, commercial after commercial, I slowly began to overdose. Then I made a disturbing discovery. The more I listened, the more I recognized the sameness of all the stations and commercials. After hours in this echo chamber, I grew bored. I wanted to hear something new or something different. Two days later, after passing through the American Heartland, the train had a one hour layover in Chicago.
我的计划是留在火车上，听棒球比赛，并阅读神奇的《蜘蛛侠》第38期。在第一局比赛中，我睡着了并做了一个梦。一种奇怪的梦。你可以称之为电台梦。现在是梦境。我在芝加哥。我离开火车座位走到外面。接着，我正走过一条秘密隧道，但我必须小心，因为里面很黑。
My plan was to stay on the train, listen to the ballgame, and read the amazing Spider-Man number 38. During the first inning, I fell asleep and had a dream. A weird kind of dream. You can call it a radio dream. And now the dream. I am in Chicago. I leave my train seat and go outside. Next, I am walking through a secret tunnel, but I had to be careful because it was dark.
隧道通向一个剧院。突然，脚灯亮了。一个穿着黑西装的瘦高个男人迈着几步走上舞台。他展开一叠油腻腻的纸开始读了起来。一个小爵士乐队在他身后开始演奏。我想让你知道我爱我的宝贝，宝贝也爱我
The tunnel led to a theater. Suddenly, the footlights come on. And a lanky man in a black suit walks up a few steps onto the stage. He unfolds a greasy sheath of papers and starts to read. A small jazz band gets to work behind him. I want you to know that I love my baby and my baby loves me
不久前我们一起出去玩 去了一个叫远方（Far Out）的地方 在中间 节奏就在那里 我伸过去握住我宝贝的手。她轻轻捏了我一下。我知道我们在同一个调上。一切开始在安静中摇曳。多年以后。我才知道这种文字与音乐的结合被称为“词爵士”（Word Jazz）。而创造它的先驱是一个名叫肯·诺丁（Ken Nordine）的人。然后我听到一声火车汽笛响，我醒了过来，猛地回到了现实中。起初，诺丁只是一个有很多话要说的作家和表演者。为了补充主要收入，他开始以
Short time ago we went out together to a place called far out up in the middle The rhythm was there I reached over and held my baby's hand. She gave me little squeeze. I knew we were in the same key. Everything was beginning to sway in a quiet years later. I would learn that this combination of writing and music was called Word Jazz. And the pioneer who created it was a man called Ken Nordin. Then I heard a train whistle and I woke up and I snapped back into reality. In the beginning Nordin was simply a writer and a performer with a lot to say. To supplement his major income he began making radio commercials in the
“词爵士”风格制作电台广告。当我们驶离芝加哥时，诺丁的一个广告通过我的朱丽叶收音机耳机播放出来，仿佛天空裂开了一般，我听到了万物之声。用你的舌头去品味柠檬。从第一口开始，你的舌头就能告诉你柠檬与众不同。如此微妙而又显而易见的事物。被一种如此显而易见却又微妙的事物所取代。然而，在昨天的舌头中有一种感觉，
word jazz style. As we pulled out of Chicago, an ordained commercial played over my Juliet radio earphone, it was as though the heavens had opened and I heated the voice of all that could be. Think with your tongue about lemon. From the first smack, your tongue can tell that lemon is something else. Something so subtly obvious. By a something so obviously subtle. Yet, there was a feeling among yesterday's tongues
那就是作为柠檬的别样美味并没有得到应有的赞赏。但那是“莎拉风味花蕾”（Shara Flavor Bud）出现之前的事了。风味花蕾没有什么秘密，除了它每次都能给你带来完美的柠檬果冻甜点。这是自树木诞生以来发生在柠檬身上最好的事情。这是自树木诞生以来发生在舌头身上最好的事情。这是自恳求诞生以来发生在舌头身上最好的事情。Flavorbot（风味花蕾）就是让这个柠檬如此具有柠檬风味的秘密所在。用标有柠檬的莎拉果冻甜点来犒劳你的家人。
that the something else that is lemon wasn't getting its just desserts. But that was before the Shara Flavor Bud. Nothing secret about Flavor Bud, except it gives you a perfect lemon jelly dessert every time. Best thing that happened to lemons since trees. Best thing that's happened for tongues since trees. Best thing that happened for tongues since please. Flavorbot is what makes this lemon so lemony lemon. Reward your family with the share of jelly dessert marked lemon.
正如任何诚实的舌头都会告诉你的那样，并非所有的果冻都是生而平等的，所以请认准莎拉果冻甜点。冲。这一次，是柠檬。这个柠檬甜点电台广告是我从未听过的，但它正是我一直在寻找的。诺丁创造了一些新鲜的东西，而且似乎凭空出现。我很喜欢它，但我并不抱太大希望还会有类似的东西出现。也许我太年轻了，没看出诺丁是未来事物的先驱。
As any honest tongue will tell you, not all jellies are created equal, so ask for share of jelly dessert. Shove. This time, lemon. The lemon dessert radio spot was like nothing I'd ever heard, but it was just what I've been searching for. Nordine had created something fresh and had seemingly came from out of nowhere. I loved it, but I didn't have much hope that anything else like this would be coming down the line. Perhaps I was too young to see that Nordine was a harbinger of things to come.
在66年夏天的最后一个星期五，我回到了布法罗，但我不会在那里待太久，因为那天晚餐时，我父亲宣布全家要搬到多伦多。只要我有我的漫画书、我的朱丽叶收音机，并且能不间断地收听我最喜欢的布法罗媒体，搬到多伦多对我来说算不了什么。见鬼，我想，这甚至可能是一件好事。作为一个在60年代长大的孩子，我不能说我喜欢商业歌曲。在60年代，我听到的所有商业歌曲都是过去广告歌的重现。当然，它们可爱得像一篮小狗，但在大多数情况下，它们不过是些没有曲调、毫无头脑的垃圾。直到1967年夏天，当一些非常奇怪的事情开始发生时
On the last Friday of the summer of 66, I arrived in Buffalo, but I wouldn't be there long because that night at dinner, my father announced the family was moving to Toronto. As long as I had my comics, my Juliet radio, and uninterrupted access to my favorite Buffalo media, the move to Toronto meant little to me. Heck, I thought, it may even be a good thing. As a child growing up in the 60s, I can't say I love jingles. In the 60s, all the jingles I heard were reiterations of jingles from the past. Sure, they were as cute as a basket of puppies, but for the most part, nothing more than tuneless, mindless, junk. That was until the summer of 1967, when some very strange things began to happen
在卑微的商业歌曲世界里。1967年，披头士乐队的唱片《佩珀中士》（Sargent Pepper）刚刚发行，流行音乐遭受了巨大的颠覆。凭借其吉他、古怪的声音以及对路易斯·卡罗尔（Lewis Carroll）和斯托克豪森（Stockhausen）的隐喻，《佩珀中士》横空出世。这个冲击力如此巨大，以至于《佩珀中士》让商业歌曲制作人们疯狂地试图以各种可能的方式复制这种新声音。我们的一个邻居，一个名叫莫特·罗斯（Mort Ross）的广告歌制作人，简直要疯了。有一天晚上在烧烤时，我记得莫特对我的母亲说，这是有史以来最大的一件事。
in the universe of the lowly jingle. In 1967, the Beatles' record, Sargent Pepper had just come out, and popular music suffered a massive disruption. With its guitars, arneard sounds, and allusions to Lewis Carroll and Stockhausen, Sargent Pepper landed with a bang. And so big was the bang, Sargent Pepper sent Jangle producers on a mad scramble to copy the new sound, and he which way they could. One of our neighbors, a Jangle producer named Mort Ross, went berserk. At a barbecue one night, I remember Mort telling my mother, this is the biggest thing ever.
我该怎么办？我怎么能和该死的披头士竞争呢？我母亲庄重地看着她刚做完美甲的手指，什么也没说。当然，披头士乐队一直以来都被拒绝为产品代言，但既然他们是披头士，那这是不可能的。然而，如果披头士不肯创作广告歌，有的是音乐人愿意。杰斐逊飞船乐队（Jefferson Airplane）在单曲《白兔》（White Rabbit）成功的喜悦中还没有回过神来，就接受了创作广告歌的邀请。这个邀请来自于
What am I going to do? How can I compete with a god damn beetles? My mother looked solemnly at her freshly manicured fingernails and said nothing. The Beatles, of course, had always been vatred to endorse products, but being the Beatles, it was not to be. However, if the Beatles wouldn't make a jingle, there were plenty of musicians who would. Still giddy from the success of their single White Rabbit, the Jefferson era plane accepted an invitation to make a jingle. The invitation, and by way of
李维斯（Levi Strauss）服装公司，他们急于吸引人们对其白色牛仔裤系列的关注。可能需要一两秒钟才能领会你在这里听到的声音，但这确实是一首广告歌。一首爱之夏的广告歌。听听格蕾丝·斯利克（Grace Slick）如何从一条白色牛仔裤中唤醒灵魂。现在，杰斐逊白色牛仔裤。现在就穿上你的白色李维斯。白色李维斯穿在黑色中，闪耀在蓝色中，我爱你。现在就穿上那些……的眼睛，现在就穿上仙人掌，在蓝色和白色中，破碎、漂浮在沙滩上
Levi Strauss, the clothing company, who were anxious to draw attention to their line of white jeans. It may take a second or two to grasp what euro back to here, but it's a jingle all right. A summer of love jingle. Listen to the way Grace licks summons the spirit from a pair of white jeans. Now, Jefferson Air White. Right now with your white Levi. White Levi's coming in black, flashing through the blue, I love you. Right now in the ohoidly eyes, right now with some cactus, in blue and white, crashing, floating, and sand
现在，配上一些白色李维斯。为了呼唤，威士忌，在一天结束时播放。现在，带着旧白色的海。毫无疑问，那个时期产出的最奇怪的商业歌曲是雷明顿电动剃须刀（Remington Electric Razors）的广告。它由弗兰克·扎帕（Frank Zappa）制作。与不知名的歌手琳达·朗斯塔特（Linda Ronstadt）组队。扎帕制作了一首极其古怪的中路广告歌，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我在路的中间，我得去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去上洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去上洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去洗手间去听一下吧。'洗手间，"布鲁克林：去洗手间。
Right now, with some white leaves eyes For calling, whiskey, play at the end of the day Right now, with the old white sea. Beyond the shadow of a doubt, the strangest jingle to come out of the period was a spot for Remington Electric Razors. It was produced by Frank Zappa. Teaming up with an unknown singer Linda Ronstadt. Zappa produced one of the most magnificently odd jingles in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm in the middle of the road, I'm gonna have to go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and go to the bathroom and you may even keep you from getting busted. Of course, senior management at Remington rejected Zappas Jingle.
当时，随着一些白叶的眼睛为了呼唤、威士忌，在一天的结束时，当下，随着旧白海。毫无疑问，那个时期出现的最奇怪的广告歌是雷明顿电动剃须刀的广告。它由弗兰克·扎帕制作。扎帕与默默无闻的歌手琳达·朗斯塔特合作，制作了中规中矩中最宏伟、最奇特的广告歌之一，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我身处其中，我得去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，去洗手间，你甚至可以避免被抓。当然，雷明顿的高层管理人员拒绝了扎帕的广告歌。
I don't know why, because Zappas Jingle is a one-of-a-kind creation. To be honest, it's the Dominion of Canada. I went to school, stumbled through the nuances of Canadian English. And because Buffalo was only 35 miles south of Toronto across Lake Ontario, I could still pick up my favorite Buffalo stations while exploring all the radio Toronto had to offer. CHUM, CBC, CFRB, the list went on. By divine intervention, my father, a gadget freak, acquired an enormous Sony 2-track reel-to-reel tape recorder on which I learned to record and edit. When I was 12, other, a gadget freak, acquired an enormous Sony 2-track real-to-real tape recorder
我不知道为什么，因为扎帕的广告歌是独一无二的创作。老实说，这里是加拿大领地。我上过学，磕磕绊绊地了解加拿大英语的细微差别。由于布法罗在安大略湖对岸，距离多伦多以南仅 35 英里，因此我在探索多伦多广播电台提供的所有内容时，仍然可以收听我最喜欢的布法罗电台。CHUM、CBC、CFRB，等等。出于天意，我的父亲是一个小玩意迷，他买了一台巨大的索尼双轨开盘式录音机，我就是在上面学会录音和剪辑的。当我 12 岁时，其他小玩意迷收购了一台巨大的索尼双轨开盘式录音机
on which I learned to record and edit. When I was 12, my voice began to break, and I saw my future. I was going to become a voice-over actor in radio commercials, and maybe if I was lucky, I'd be on TV commercials too. One step at a time I warned myself. One step at a time. My voice over nom de plume was Chris Christensen. Reading into the Sunday Tape recorder as Chris, I practiced every day. I read copy from a magazine ad to make my first radio commercial. It was an experience in humility. Take one. A lot of cigarettes from a tape, but for me, only one cigarette delivers, and
我在上面学会了录音和剪辑。当我 12 岁时，我的声音开始变声，我看到了我的未来。我将成为一名广播广告配音演员，如果运气好的话，我也会参加电视广告。我警告自己，一步一个脚印。一步一个脚印。我的配音笔名是克里斯·克里斯滕森。作为克里斯对着周日的录音机朗读，我每天都在练习。我朗读杂志广告中的文案来制作我的第一个广播广告。这是一次谦卑的经历。第一条。磁带里有很多烟草广告，但对我和我来说，只有一种烟草能带来
that's the route. Take two. A lot of cigarettes. In seventh grade, I had a friend who intentionally dressed and wore his hair to look like Andy Warhol. His name was Taylor Reed. Taylor's father, Mr. Reed, was the Count Executive at the ad firm McCann Erickson. McCann Erickson's biggest client was Coca-Cola. On weekends, when Taylor's dad had custody of Taylor, I would often tag along, and the three of us would hang out at Mr. Reed's office at McCann. One Sunday, in February, Mr. Reed took us into the boardroom.
那就是这条路。第二条。很多烟草。在七年级时，我有一个朋友，他刻意穿着打扮，留着安迪·沃霍尔的发型。他的名字叫泰勒·里德。泰勒的父亲里德先生是广告公司麦肯埃里克的客户总监。麦肯埃里克最大的客户是可口可乐。周末，当泰勒的爸爸拥有泰勒的监护权时，我经常会跟着去，我们三个人会在里德先生在麦肯的办公室闲逛。二月的一个星期天，里德先生把我们带进了董事会会议室。
We sat down, and he explained he had a top secret radio project to show us, and he wanted our opinion. Then he pressed the button, the curtains closed, the lights went down, we sat in the dark and waited. And then a voice of such angelic purity peers through the silence, and the hair on the back of my neck stood up. I'd like to buy the world a home and finish it with love. Grow up on trees and honey bees
我们坐下来，他向我们解释说，他有一个最高机密的广播项目要向我们展示，他想要征求我们的意见。然后他按下按钮，窗帘拉上，灯光熄灭，我们坐在黑暗中等待。然后，一个纯洁如天使般的声音穿透了寂静，我脖子后面的汗毛都竖了起来。我想买一个世界给它一个家，并用爱来装饰它。在树上和蜜蜂间长大
So white, turtle does. I'd like to teach the world to sing with me. I'd like to buy the world a home To sing with me A big, common, a big common I like to buy the world of coke I keep it company and the real I like to keep the world of silver I want to marry on a big, big, big, big
如此雪白，斑鸠也是如此。我想教世界和我一起歌唱。我想买一个世界给它一个家与我一起歌唱 一个巨大、普通的、巨大的普通的 我想给世界买可口可乐 我陪伴着它，这是真实的我喜欢让世界保持银色 我想娶一个巨大、巨大、巨大、巨大
And I'd like to buy the world of coke And keep it company's the real thing What the world wants today Oh, never come, it's the real thing What the world wants today It's the real thing After the new Coke jingle played, Mr. Reed said, so what do you boys think?
而且我想给世界买可口可乐并陪伴它，这就是真实的这就是世界今天想要的哦，绝不，这是真实的这就是世界今天想要的这就是真实的在新的可口可乐广告歌播放后，里德先生说，孩子们，你们觉得怎么样？
We gave a thumbs up, and boy, were we right. The simple words and melody of the new Coke jingle suggested that the clearest path to utopia was through the mouth of a Coke bottle. Still, preposterous or not, to this day, I'd like to buy the world of coke remains one of the most popular jingles in the history of radio. When FM radio came on the scene, I put my Julia portable transistor radio in retirement and acquired a new portable Panasonic radio with AMFM reception and stereo
我们竖起了大拇指，天哪，我们猜对了。新可口可乐广告歌简单的歌词和旋律暗示通往乌托邦的最清晰途径是通过可口可乐瓶口。尽管荒谬与否，直到今天，“我想买一瓶可口可乐”仍然是广播史上最受欢迎的广告歌之一。当调频广播出现时，我将朱丽叶便携式晶体管收音机退役，并购买了一台具备 AMFM 接收和立体声功能的新松下便携式收音机
ear plugs. The new radio was smaller than a paperback, yet bigger than the Juliet. Every Saturday and Sunday night, I would lie on my bed in the dark and toggle across the frequency band of my Panasonic in search of new things to hear. At that time, I was very excited that I had discovered the concept of irony. I was always on the outlook for tiny, ironic moments to test my new capacity for irony detection. My solitary weekend listening parties typically went something like this. Saturday night, 10 p.m. WGR radio, Buffalo, tuned into Larry King, topic the Vietnam War
耳塞。这台新收音机比平装书还小，但比朱丽叶收音机大。每周六和周日晚上，我会躺在黑暗的床上，在松下的频段上切换，寻找新鲜的收音内容。当时，我非常兴奋，因为我发现了反讽的概念。我一直在寻找微小的反讽时刻来测试我新获得的识别反讽的能力。我孤独的周末收听派对通常是这样的。周六晚上 10 点。布法罗 WGR 电台，收听拉里·金节目，话题是越南战争
with actor Jane Fonda. He'll always be part of you at all. Always. But so will Tom Hayden and so would Vadim except he died. Memorable moment? An army recruitment ad, produced by Ken Nordein, yes the same word jazz Ken Nordeinite heard in Chicago, played right after Jane delivered a rousing speech about the hypocrisy and evil
嘉宾是演员简·方达。他永远是你的一部分。永远。但汤姆·海登也是，瓦迪姆也是，除了他去世了。难忘的时刻？一则由肯·诺德海因制作的军队招兵广告，是的，就是我在芝加哥听过的那位爵士乐手肯·诺德海因，在简发表了一番关于伪善和邪恶的慷慨激昂的演讲后立即播出
of the military industrial complex. Young man, are you haunted by a fear of failure? You're right, Alex. Young man, are you haunted by a fear of failure? Chain to a dull job with no future? When the door to opportunity swings open, and success awaits, do you have a ghost of a chance? Don't despair. You're still young. There's still time. Time to escape from a dreary future. How? Choose your own job training in today's army. And say goodbye to the evil eye. You can choose dumb training before you at list, before you at list, in the modern army.
军工复合体。年轻人，你被失败的恐惧所困扰吗？你说得对，亚历克斯。年轻人，你被失败的恐惧所困扰吗？被锁在枯燥且没有未来的工作中吗？当机会之门敞开，成功在召唤时，你有一丝机会吗？不要绝望。你还年轻。还有时间。是时候逃离沉闷的未来了。如何？在今天的军队中选择你自己的职业培训。跟邪恶的眼睛说再见。你可以在入伍前，在入伍前，在现代军队中选择哑巴训练。
Sunday night, 8 p.m. Chama fam Toronto. Show the FireSign Theater. Ladies and gentlemen of the radio public tonight, athletes in action, the heaviest show you'll ever see. A surreal stream of consciousness comedy radio show produced in Los Angeles that often made coded references to recreational drug use. Usually marijuana.
周日晚上 8 点。多伦多 Chama fam。播放火象剧院。广播公众的女士们先生们，今晚，行动中的运动员，你们看过的最沉重的节目。一档在洛杉矶制作的超现实意识流喜剧广播节目，其中经常包含对消遣性吸毒（通常是大麻）的隐晦提及。
Memorable moment, the Canadian Department of Health was a key sponsor of the FireSign Theatre Show. So during commercial breaks, listeners were bombarded by endless rounds of anti-drug PSAs. Like this weird contribution starring Indian classical musician Ravi Shankar. This is Ravi Shankar. You young ones, you have the elixir of life. You don't need hard cuts to make your life more meaningful. In high school, I was a loner, a real holding coffee old. But I managed to avoid most of the humiliating pitfalls of adolescence
难忘的时刻，加拿大卫生部是火象剧院节目的主要赞助商。因此在商业广告期间，听众会遭到无休止的反毒品公益广告的轰炸。就像这个由印度古典音乐家拉维·香卡主演的奇怪广告。我是拉维·香卡。你们年轻人，你们拥有生命的长生不老药。你们不需要硬切来让你们的生活更有意义。在高中时，我是一个独行侠，一个真正的老咖啡，但我设法避开了青春期大部分羞辱性的陷阱
with a rapier wit, all of its stolen from George Carlin, and because I was always wearing earphones. After graduation, I took the radio and television arts course at Ryerson University, where I excelled at reading weather reports on the student radio station CFRM. On sunny days, I would call for rain. On chilly days, I would call for warmth. I was a real barrel of stupid collegiate laughs. After my freshman year at Ryerson, I got lucky and landed a summer job as a boy Friday at a Toronto recording studio called Morgan Earl Sounds. I was the lowest run on the ladder. My daily duties included, backhuming, picking up my boss's dry cleaning, cataloging tapes, an endlessly restocking mid-priced wine for our clientele of attractive ad agency creative department workers.
凭借着犀利的机智，全都是从乔治·卡林那里偷来的，而且因为我总是戴着耳机。毕业后，我在瑞尔森大学攻读广播和电视艺术课程，在学生广播电台 CFRM 播报天气预报时表现出色。在晴天，我会呼吁下雨。在寒冷的日子里，我会呼吁温暖。我真是个大学里愚蠢的笑料。在瑞尔森读完大一后，我很幸运地在多伦多一家名为 Morgan Earl Sounds 的录音室找到了一份杂工的暑期工作。我是公司里地位最低的员工。我的日常工作包括：扫地、帮老板取干洗衣服、给磁带归类，以及为我们那些精美的广告公司创意部门员工客户无休止地重新进货中档葡萄酒。
These were the beautiful people and now I was among them. Morgan Earl sounds specialized in making two things, radio commercials and jingles. On any given day, I'd hear an amazing cortege of radio commercials with the voices of Catherine O'Hara, Eugene Levy, Rick Moranis and John Candy. None of whom were household names yet. Hey, come on, we're paying you to say door vowel circle, huh? Harland autumn. As easy to get to, as they are to talk to.
这些是俊男美女，现在我也成了他们的一员。Morgan Earl 声音公司专门制作两样东西，广播广告和广告歌。在任何特定的一天，我都会听到一连串精彩的广播广告，里面有凯瑟琳·欧哈拉、尤金·列维、里克·莫拉尼斯和约翰·坎迪的声音。他们当时都不是家喻户晓的名字。嘿，得了吧，我们付钱给你是为了让你说门瓦勒圆环，对吧？哈兰·奥托。去那里就像跟他们交谈一样容易。
Easy root number one. Take the Metropolitan to the Coat Delias Exits and follow Coat Delias to the Winter Circle. It's Harland Auto at the Door Valorcer. Excuse me. Or, Easy root number two. Take the Transcandid of the Sources Boulevard. Go south on sources to highways 2 and 20, then west to the Winter Circle. It's Door Valorcer. Can you say that?
简单路线一。乘坐大都会线到科特德利亚斯出口，然后沿着科特德利亚斯前往温特圆环。这就是位于门瓦勒瑟的哈兰汽车。打扰一下。或者，简单路线二。乘坐跨加拿大高速公路到索尔斯大道。向南行驶至 2 号和 20 号高速公路，然后向西前往温特圆环。这就是门瓦勒瑟。你能说这个吗？
Move your mouth. Move your mouth. Door Val, Door Val, we're paying you the money. Once you're there, circle. Can you say that? Move your mouth. Move your mouth. Door valve, door valve. We're paying you the money. Once you're there, you're where you should be for the best in General Motors car sales and service. Harlan Otto has been there for years, and for years they've been the automatic choice.
动动你的嘴。动动你的嘴。门瓦勒，门瓦勒，我们付给你钱。一旦你到了那里，圆环。你能说这个吗？动动你的嘴。动动你的嘴。门瓦勒，门瓦勒。我们付给你钱。一旦你到了那里，你就在你该去的地方，享受最优质的通用汽车销售和服务。哈兰·奥托已经在那里经营多年，多年来他们一直是自动选择。
Thinking GM, think Harlan. Look for them at the winter circle. Are you having problems at home or something? You can't read the script. I mean, it's right there in front of you. Door valve. I've had enough of you. What do you mean? Leave me alone.
想买通用汽车，就选哈兰。在温特圆环寻找他们。你在家里遇到什么问题了吗？你读不懂剧本。我的意思是，它就在你眼前。门瓦勒。我受够你了。什么意思？离我远点。
Leave your learn. I'll leave you alone. As easy to get to. As they are to talk to. Harland Aura at the Winner's Circle. Door go. It's a door. Hey, the door.
离我远点。我会离你远点的。去那里就像跟他们交谈一样容易。位于优胜者圆环的哈兰奥拉。门去。这是一扇门。嘿，这扇门。
After two days on the job, I was shocked when one of the senior producers invited me into the studio to witness the production of a radio commercial. For listeners, we have never set foot in a recording studio. Here's how it looks. The recording environment is comprised of two rooms, a studio, and a control room. The studio is soundproofed and contains microphones and headphones for the performers. The control room has a variety of speakers, recording devices, and a mixing console, which allows you to edit and assemble the recorded material. There is also a plush seating that includes leather-bound sofas to catch the occasional spilled drink.
在工作两天后，当其中一位高级制作人邀请我进入录音室见证广播广告的制作时，我震惊了。对于从未踏入过录音室的听众来说。情况是这样的。录音环境由两个房间组成，即录音室和控制室。录音室是隔音的，里面为表演者配有麦克风和耳机。控制室拥有各种扬声器、录音设备和调音台，可让您编辑和组装录音材料。还有毛绒座椅，包括皮革装订的沙发，以防偶尔洒出的饮料。
In those days, the control room air was rich in the unmistakable aroma of Ampex 456 recording tape. A scented recalls, campfire smoke, and styrofoam packing peanuts. There were asteris everywhere, and strewn around the room like sleepy domestic house cats, where the coterie of writers, producers, and client representatives. Given the often experimental aesthetic of the time, and the success of Second City and Saturday Night Live, many commercial recording sessions relied not on scripts, but on the improvisational talent of the performers. I remember being at Morgan Earl one night and watching Second City Record a commercial for an upcoming federal election.
在那几天里，控制室的空气中弥漫着安派克 456 录音带那独特的香气。这种气味让人想起营火烟雾和聚苯乙烯泡沫塑料包装花生。到处都是星号，像沉睡的家猫一样散落在房间周围的是一群作家、制作人和客户代表。鉴于当时经常具有实验性的美学，以及第二城和周六夜现场的成功，许多商业录音会议不依赖剧本，而是依赖表演者的即兴表演天赋。我记得有一天晚上在摩根伯爵，看着第二城为即将到来的联邦选举录制商业广告。
Here's an outtake from that session. What do you think we have to do to get people involved in politics? I say we get rent buses for them and force them to go to these meetings. I see. Well, what do you think we have to do to get people involved in politics? I think we should send them more letters, I tell them what's happening, and make them read them. Excuse me, what do you think we're gonna have to do
这是该会议的未采用片段。你认为我们必须做些什么来让人们参与政治？我说我们为他们租辆公共汽车，强迫他们去参加这些会议。我明白了。好吧，你认为我们必须做些什么来让人们参与政治？我认为我们应该给他们发送更多的信件，告诉他们发生了什么，并让他们阅读。对不起，你认为我们必须做什么
to get people involved in politics and good government? Well, I say if they don't go to the meeting, she attacks them, just attacks them real heavy. Hit them where it hurts in the pocket. I see. Political parties should be parties. I think that's what people are attracted to. They're attracted to fun.
让人们参与到政治和优秀的政府管理中来？嗯，我说如果他们不去开会，她就会抨击他们，狠狠地抨击。戳中他们的痛处，让他们破财。我明白了。政党就应该像个政党。我想这也是吸引人们的地方。他们被趣味性所吸引。
And you make politics fun, and you got a lot of people involved. One of the great things about working at Morgan Earl were the out of town guests. Henry Winkler, William Shattner, and Alice Cooper. All stopped by for one reason or another. A familiar face at the studio was San Francisco-based radio writer, interviewer, and genius, Mal Sharpe. Mal's specialty is the man on the street radio commercial. I spent one day as a tape operator assisting Mal recording some commercials outside. He wore a trench coat and a stylish fedora.
只要你把政治变得有趣，你就能吸引很多人参与进来。在摩根厄尔工作最棒的一点之一就是能见到外地来的嘉宾。亨利·温克勒、威廉·沙特纳和爱丽丝·库珀。他们都因为各种原因顺道拜访过。工作室里有一个熟悉的面孔，那就是旧金山的电台作家、采访者兼天才马尔·夏普。马尔的专长是街头采访类的电台广告。我有幸当了一天磁带操作员，协助马尔在户外录制一些广告。他穿着一件风衣，戴着一顶时尚的软呢帽。
Mal is one of the most fascinating and charismatic men I have ever met. Of the many lessons Mal taught me that day, the most important lesson in fact was how to talk with complete strangers. Mal could talk to almost anyone because he knew the power of kindness. Well, this is Mal's sharp along with Ernie Anderson. And of course, in the background, you hear the people of California chanting for Belbran to defeat the rival chip.
马尔是我见过的最迷人、最有个人魅力的男士之一。在那天马尔教给我的众多课程中，最重要的一课实际上是如何与完全陌生的人交谈。马尔几乎能和任何人聊天，因为他深知善意的力量。好吧，这位是马尔·夏普，还有埃尔尼·安德森。当然，在背景音里，你能听到加利福尼亚的人们在高喊着让贝尔布兰打败竞争对手的薯片。
You can hear them as they sing. Belba brand, Belba brand, Belba brand, and the background. It's a man you're out here and you can hear these people If you think this is gonna be good for sales. Well, it's a new thing. It's a new in thing. Do you understand what they're chanting? Doesn't sound like potato chips at all. What is a sound like? It sounds like an Indian chant. Yeah. I mean, it's in Congress. So, in summation, you think it's going to be a good year for bell-brand potato chips, as long as there's chance.
你能听到他们在歌唱。背景音里喊着：贝尔布兰，贝尔布兰，贝尔布兰。你作为一个局外人来到这里，听到这些人喊着，如果你认为这对销量有好处的话。嗯，这是一种新事物。这是一种新潮事物。你明白他们在喊什么吗？听起来一点也不像薯片。那听起来像什么？听起来像印第安人的呐喊。是的。我的意思是，这在国会里。所以，总而言之，只要有这些呐喊声，你认为今年对贝尔品牌薯片来说会是好的一年吗？
I don't think so. I think it's going to be a good year for bell-brand. Regardless of the chanting, because their product is so good. Fresh crispy and yummy. Oh, very. Now what else do you want from me? Come on! If it's bell, it's swell.
我不这么认为。我认为对贝尔品牌来说，这将是丰收的一年。不管有没有呐喊声，因为他们的产品太棒了。新鲜酥脆又美味。哦，非常棒。现在你还想从我这里得到什么？得了吧！如果是贝尔的，那就是绝佳的。
Did you notice the pint-sized musical flourish at the end of the Bell potato chip spot? It's called a tag. Tags belong to a musical genre that began as an experiment for a waning breakfast cereal in 1926. What began as an audio experiment for a waning breakfast cereal in 1926? Would, over the next five decades, become a distinct musical form. It's called a jingle. Although, I was exposed to thousands of jingles in my childhood,
你注意到贝尔薯片广告结尾处那个小巧玲珑的音乐尾声了吗？这被称为“小尾巴”（tag）。小尾巴属于一种音乐流派，它始于1926年为一种日渐式微的早餐麦片所做的一次实验。1926年，作为针对一款日渐式微的早餐麦片的音频实验，最终在接下来的五十年里，演变成了一种独特的音乐形式。它被称为广告歌（jingle）。虽然我在童年时期接触过成千上万首广告歌，
two of which you've already heard, who would have known there was a creative jingle explosion looming just around the corner. Jingles have been around since the beginning of radio, but in the 1970s, we hit peak Jingle. But since they fell out of fashion so long ago, this may be a good time to review, but actually makes a Jingle, a Jingle. Jingles always have a catchy melody that's easy to sing. They must be earworms, burrowing their way in and staying there for days. Lyrically, some jingles try to create a vague atmosphere of desire in a listener's imagination. Other kinds of jingles play to the listener with more specific appeals, underlining the
其中有两首你已经听过了，但谁曾料到，一场富有创意的广告歌爆发正悄然来临呢？广告歌自广播诞生之初就已存在，但在20世纪70年代，我们迎来了广告歌的巅峰时期。但由于它们淡出时尚圈已经太久，现在或许是个好时机来回顾一下，究竟是什么让广告歌成为广告歌。广告歌总是有一段朗朗上口、易于哼唱的旋律。它们一定得是那种“洗脑神曲”，能够钻进你的脑子里并在那里停留数天。在歌词方面，一些广告歌试图在听众的想象中营造一种模糊的渴望氛围。另一些类型的广告歌则通过更具体的诉求来吸引听众，强调
virtue of a product's price, speed, sexiness, or mouth-watering ingredients. To all be fatty special sauce, lettuce, cheese, trickles, and a set of special sauce, traditional jingles come with a chorus of singers who repeat a catchphrase or tagline near the end. On your own, on your own, we hold it! But what a jingle really does is bind an emotion to a product or service. From sunbaths in the east to the sun setting the west We're America's hands, do it what we do, do it what we do best! By design, Jingles bypass the analytical lobes in the brain and instead stimulate the
产品价格、速度、性感或令人垂涎的配料等优点。全是高脂肪的特制酱料、生菜、奶酪、酸黄瓜，还有一套特制酱料，传统的广告歌都会伴随着一组歌手，在接近尾声时重复一句朗朗上口的标语或口号。全靠自己，全靠自己，我们顶住！但广告歌真正的作用是将一种情感与某项产品或服务绑定在一起。从东边的日浴到西边的夕阳，我们是美国的双手，做我们所做的事，做到最好！按照设计，广告歌绕过了大脑中的分析叶，反而刺激了
nucleus of condoms or pleasure centers. Once you hear it, a jingle creates an itch that you can't stop scratching. Between 1970 and 1980, ad companies produced thousands of jingles, and for a good reason. Change was in the air. In the 1970s, a new generation of very sophisticated young jinglewriters flooded the jingle jungle and couldn't help but write music that appealed to their generation. But none of this came as a big surprise to me, because in many ways, I was one of them. Growing up on a diet of steely-dann and Joni Mitchell, how could I not have been? Take Dr. Pepper The first time I heard it be a pepper in
核心喜悦区或快乐中枢。一旦你听到它，广告歌就会产生一种让你欲罢不能的“瘙痒感”。在1970年到1980年间，广告公司制作了成千上万首广告歌，这是有充分理由的。变革的气息弥漫在空气中。在20世纪70年代，新一代非常成熟年轻的广告歌创作者涌入了广告歌的丛林，他们情不自禁地创作出吸引他们这一代人的音乐。但这对我来说并不算什么大惊小怪的事，因为在许多方面，我就是他们中的一员。在听着斯特利·丹和琼尼·米歇尔的音乐长大的背景下，我又怎么可能不是呢？以Dr. Pepper（胡椒博士）为例，我第一次听到“成为一名胡椒粉”是在1977年，
77, I had to pull over to the side of the road. Randy Newman and Jake Holmes wrote the jingle which begins with a startling statement. I drink Dr. Pepper because I'm proud. I used to be alone in a crowd. What? A Dr. Pepper bottled a cure for alienation? Let's take a sip and see. Pepper 2 I'm a pepper, he's a pepper, she's a pepper If you drink Dr. Pepper, you're a pepper 2 Us peppers are an interesting breed An original taste is what we need Asking if pepper and is safe Only Dr. Pepper tastes that way
我不得不把车停在路边。兰迪·纽曼和杰克·霍尔姆斯创作了这首广告歌，它以一个惊人的声明开场。我喝胡椒博士是因为我骄傲。我曾经在人群中孤立无援。什么？一瓶胡椒博士竟然是消除疏离感的良药？让我们喝上一口来看看。胡椒2号，我是胡椒，他是胡椒，她是胡椒，如果你喝胡椒博士，你也是胡椒。我们胡椒粉是一个有趣的品种，我们需要的是原汁原味的口感。询问胡椒是否安全，只有胡椒博士才有那种味道。
I'm a pepper, he's a pepper, she's a pepper Where a pepper, what do you like to be a pepper 2? I'm a pepper, he's a pepper, she's a pepper, where a pepper, what'd you like to be a pepper, too? I'm a pepper, he's a pepper, she's a pepper, where a pepper, what'd you like to be a pepper, too? Be a pepper, treat, doctor, pepper, come on! Be a pepper, treat, doctor, pepper, right? Be a pepper, treat, doctor, pepper, be a pepper, treat Dr. Pepa. For me, B.A. Pepper was an awakening. Listers were calling radio stations requesting to hear B.A. Pepper as though it were a hit song.
我是胡椒，他是胡椒，她是胡椒，我们是胡椒，你也想当胡椒吗？我是胡椒，他是胡椒，她是胡椒，我们是胡椒，你也想当胡椒吗？我是胡椒，他是胡椒，她是胡椒，我们是胡椒，你也想当胡椒吗？当个胡椒吧，请尝尝胡椒博士，来吧！当个胡椒吧，请尝尝胡椒博士，对吧？当个胡椒吧，请尝尝胡椒博士，当个胡椒吧，请尝尝胡椒博士。对我来说，“成为胡椒”是一次觉醒。听众们纷纷打电话到电台，要求播放“成为胡椒”，就好像它是一首热门歌曲一样。
The power of this fact wasn't lost on me. At 20 years old, I began producing radio commercials. Then I joined the musician and actors union and began writing, playing and singing on jungles. Ribblubber's festival was on now 1695 only at Boston Beach. Reading the union newsletters, I discovered the Toronto was a hub of jingle innovation, but that the real center of the jingle universe was New York. And so, like thousands of story-eyed kids with a dream, in 1984, I moved to Gotham City, found an apartment, and hit the pavement with my demo tape in hand. apartment and hit the pavement with my demo tape in hand. As luck would have it, I was soon working. During my New York journey, I was a writer and a producer.
这一事实的力量并没有被我忽视。20岁时，我开始制作电台广告。后来我加入了音乐家和演员工会，并开始在广告歌中进行词曲创作、演奏和演唱。“里布勒的节日现在只要1695，仅限波士顿海滩。”阅读工会通讯时，我发现多伦多是广告歌创新的中心，但广告歌真正的宇宙中心是纽约。于是，就像成千上万怀揣梦想、眼界开阔的孩子一样，在1984年，我搬到了哥谭市，找了一间公寓，手里拿着我的小样磁带走上了街头。手里拿着小样磁带找工作。正如命运所安排的那样，我很快就找到工作了。在纽约的这段旅程中，我既是作家又是制作人。
I worked for ad agencies and sound production companies. I listened as Radio Ads shortened from 60 seconds to 30 seconds. A gasp as creativity was often crushed by an increasingly powerful beast called Market Research. Yet despite the many obstacles, I was always in the studio doing what I loved most. Making radio. Radio. No matter what place I am, or era, I'm living in. One thing has always been clear to me. Radio commercials are never the main course.
我为广告公司和声音制作公司工作。我听着电台广告从60秒缩短到30秒。我倒吸一口凉气，因为创意经常被一个日益强大的名为“市场研究”的怪兽所粉碎。然而，尽管有重重阻碍，我始终在录音室里做着我最热爱的事。制作广播。广播。无论我身处何地，或生活在哪个时代。有一件事对我来说始终是清晰的。电台广告从来都不是主菜。
Like the complimentary basket of garlic bread bread you get at an Italian restaurant. Radio commercials are not something you order, but rather something you expect and sometimes take delight in. Of course, unlike today's complimentary basket of garlic bread, the very first radio commercial was written and produced without a known format to follow. No one knew how short or how long it should be, and if it would work at all, and what if anything would happen after it went to air. On August 28, 1922, a W.E.A.F. radio in New York. A man called Mr. Blackwell stood behind a mic and urged unsuspecting listeners to leave Matt Hatton.
就像你在意大利餐厅里吃到的免费大蒜面包篮一样。电台广告不是你点单买来的，而是你所期待的，有时甚至会从中获得乐趣。当然，与如今免费的大蒜面包篮不同，最早的电台广告在创作和制作时并没有已知的格式可循。没有人知道它应该有多短或多长，它是否会起作用，以及如果播出后会发生什么（如果有的话）。1922年8月28日，在纽约的WEAF电台。一个叫布莱克韦尔先生的人站在麦克风后面，敦促毫无防备的听众搬离马特·哈顿。
For the family friendly, tree-lined streets of Jackson Heights in the borough of Queens, if living in New York was getting on your nerves, Mr. Blackwell had news for you. A magical new place called a heart-th court, apartment homes. Listen to Blackwell's pitch for this exciting new place to live. Your health may depend on it. Friends, you owe it to your self and your family. The music and guest at city. And enjoy what needs to be intended you to enjoy. Visit our new apartment homes in Boston course, Jackson Heights,
前往位于皇后区的杰克逊高地那些适合家庭居住、绿树成荫的街道。如果住在纽约让你感到心烦意乱，布莱克韦尔先生有好消息要告诉您。一个神奇的新地方，叫做“哈斯霍恩阁楼公寓”。听听布莱克韦尔对于这个令人兴奋的新居住地的推销。你的健康可能就取决于此。朋友们，这是你对你自己和家人应尽的责任。城市的音乐与客房。并享受理应让你享受的一切。参观我们在波士顿球场的全新公寓住宅，杰克逊高地，
where you may enjoy community life in a friendly environment. History doesn't say what happened to Blackwell, but response to the radio commercial was overwhelming because within days, the vacant apartments of hearthorn core Department Homes were felt. All of this because of one simple radio commercial. When word of the Harthorn radio miracle spread, every station in New York understood the potential and rushed into the fray. Finally, seeing a way to make real money, radio embraced commercials and radio commercials became a mainstay of the radio experience. What began as an audio experiment some 90 years ago eventually became a worldwide industry worth billions of dollars.
在那里你可以在友好的环境中享受社区生活。历史没有记载布莱克韦尔后来怎么样了，但对这个电台广告的反应是压倒性的，因为几天之内，哈斯霍恩阁楼公寓里空置的公寓就住满了。这一切都归功于一个简单的电台广告。当哈斯霍恩的广播奇迹传开后，纽约的每一个电台都明白了其中的潜力，并蜂拥而至。最终，广播看到了赚钱的切实途径，开始拥抱广告，电台广告也成为了广播体验的中流砥柱。大约90年前作为音频实验开始的事物，最终演变成了一个价值数十亿美元的全球产业。
Brilliant or silly, thought-provoking or moving, the humble radio commercial became the fuel you could say that allows radio to play the news, music, and stories we've been listening to ever since. For the Organist, from KCRW and McSweeney's, Unclive Desmond. This was just an edited version of Part 1 of Clive Desmond's two-part personal history of radio advertising. To hear the rest, check out the organist from K-Shar W. and McSweeney's. There's a link on our website. While we're on the subject of the sound of radio changing our lives,
无论是精妙还是愚蠢，是引人深思还是令人感动，这个不起眼的电台广告成为了推动力，可以说正是它让广播得以播放我们一直以来收听的新闻、音乐和故事。来自KCRW和《麦 Sweeney's》杂志的《管风琴师》，我是克莱夫·德斯蒙德。这只是克莱夫·德斯蒙德关于广播广告个人历史的两部分节目的第一部分的精简版。想要收听其余部分，请查看来自KCRW和《麦 Sweeney's》的《管风琴师》。我们的网站上有链接。在我们讨论广播声音改变我们生活这个话题的同时，
I wanted to share a clip of me talking about my first favorite radio story, which isn't a radio story at all. It's from a movie. That's right after this. So my friend Chuck Bryant is one half of the charming Josh and Chuck of the original Nerd Out on Tiny Details podcast called Stuff You Should Know. It's probably the first podcast I ever listened to and I still love it, me and them because Josh and Chalka are just so great to spend time with. Well, anyway, Chuck has this new podcast that's really fantastic. It's called Movie Crush, where he invites people he likes to talk about their favorite movie of all time.
我想分享一段我谈论自己最喜欢的第一个广播故事的片段，它其实根本不是一个广播故事。它出自一部电影。马上回来。我的朋友查克·布莱恩特是播客鼻祖《你应该知道的事》（Stuff You Should Know）里那对迷人的乔治和查克二人组的一半。这大概是我听过的第一个播客，我至今仍然很喜欢它，我和他们一样，因为乔治和查克在一起度过时光实在是太棒了。不管怎样，查克有一个非常精彩的新播客。它叫《电影迷恋》（Movie Crush），他在节目中邀请自己喜欢的人来谈论他们有史以来最喜欢的电影。
And I went on to talk about Jaws. Now, I love Jaws. And so does Chuck actually and my favorite scene is when the shark hunter quint Tells the story of him being left in the water after his ship the USS Indianapolis was sunk in World War 2 So here's a part of that monologue Japanese submarine slam two torpedoes into our side chief It's coming back The island of Tinian the lady just delivered the bomb, the Hiroshima bomb. I'm 100 men when in the water. Vessel went down in 12 minutes. Didn't see the first shark for about half an hour.
我上节目谈论了《大白鲨》。现在，我很喜欢《大白鲨》。查克其实也很喜欢，我最喜欢的一个场景是，鲨鱼猎人昆特讲述他在第二次世界大战中乘坐的美国海军“印第安纳波利斯”号战舰被击沉后，自己被留在水中的故事。所以这是那段独白的其中一部分。日本潜水艇向我们的船舷发射了两枚鱼雷，长官。它又回来了。天宁岛，那位女士刚刚运送了炸弹，广岛炸弹。当时有一百人在水里。船在12分钟内沉没。大约半小时后才看到第一条鲨鱼。
Tiger, 13 footer, you know, you know that when you're in the water chief, you tell by looking from the dorsal to the tail. Well, we didn't know. Which our bomb mission had been so secret. No distress signal had been sent. They didn't even list his overdue for a week. Very first leg, chief. Sharks come cruising.
虎鲨，13英尺长，你知道的，你知道当你身处水中时，长官，你可以通过看从背鳍到尾巴来判断。好吧，我们不知道。因为我们的轰炸任务太机密了。没有发送求救信号。他们甚至过了一周才把我们列为逾期未归。第一条腿，长官。鲨鱼开始游弋。
So we formed ourselves into tight groups. You know, it's kind of like old squares in a battle. Like you see in a calendar, like the battle of Waterloo, and the idea was, Sharks comes the nearest man there, and when he's that pounding, hollering, and screaming, sometimes the Shaq go away. Sometimes he wouldn't go away. Sometimes that Shaq he looks right into you. Might into your eyes. You know the thing about a Shaq he's got lifeless eyes. Black eyes, is that lifeless eyes. Black eyes, like a doll's eyes.
于是我们把自己排成紧密的方阵。你知道，这有点像战斗中的老式方阵。就像你在日历上看到的滑铁卢战役那样，当时的想法是，鲨鱼会靠近最近的人，当他那样大喊大叫、尖叫时，有时鲨鱼会游走。有时它不会游走。有时那条鲨鱼会直勾勾地看着你。直视你的双眼。你知道鲨鱼最可怕的地方吗？它有一双毫无生气的眼睛。黑色的眼睛，就像毫无生气的眼睛。黑色的眼睛，像洋娃娃的眼睛。
Oh, it's okay. Anyway, here's a clip of me talking to Chuck Bryant about that scene on Movie Crush. I love radio so much, and I love the storytelling in radio. It is still like my ideal form, and I think of Quint's story as the first radio story I ever really loved. It's like, it is told just perfectly. Like you could almost see it. Like the story core music starts and then yeah, like know like on morning edition and then Quentin starts and you can remember some teenager going, oh my god, I can't believe it. On the other side, it is a perfectly told natural. I think I just think it's a radio
哦，没关系。无论如何，这是我和查克·布莱恩特在《电影迷恋》中谈论那个场景的片段。我太喜欢广播了，我喜欢广播里的故事讲述。它依然像是我的理想形式，我认为昆特的这个故事是我真正喜欢的第一个广播故事。就像，它讲得太完美了。简直就像你能亲眼看到一样。就像故事核心音乐开始响起，然后，是的，就像在《早间新闻》里一样，昆特开始讲述，你仿佛能记住某个青少年说，哦天哪，我真不敢相信。从另一方面来看，这是一个完美讲述的自然故事。我想我只是觉得这是一个广播
story. I would cut it out and put on the radio in a heartbeat. It's like perfect. And it's funny because there's all this stuff, all this great activity you've already had, the adventure music playing, you know, and the barrels and shooting it and everything, but that moment is so riveting. I love it. That's my favorite moment in the movie. I mean, one of mine for sure,
故事。我会毫不犹豫地把它剪辑下来放到广播里播放。它简直完美。有趣的是，这里有所有这些内容，所有你已经经历过的精彩活动，播放着冒险音乐，你知道的，还有那些木桶、射击以及一切，但那个时刻太引人入胜了。我太喜欢了。这是电影中最让我心动的时刻。我的最爱之一，绝对是。
and the backstory there for that scene was that, that was not in the book, and Spielberg brought in the great screenwriter and filmmaker John Millius to write that monologue and then apparently Robert Shaw himself too who's a playwright went in and and did some rewriting on it and kind of worked with Millius on it and You know just ends up being like one of the most iconic monologues in movie history for sure
那个场景的幕后故事是，剧本里原本没有这一段，斯皮尔伯格找来了伟大的编剧兼电影制作人约翰·米利厄斯来写这段独白，然后显然罗伯特·肖本人——他也是一位剧作家——也参与进来，对它进行了一些重写，并与米利厄斯一起对它进行了打磨，你知道的，最终它成为了电影史上最具标志性的独白之一，这是绝对的。
It is so good and it so naturally moved from one scene to the scar of comparison to the other. And the fact that I've thought about this a lot, it's like, it's called out because there are comparing scars and Brody says, what's that on your arm? And it's the removal of the tattoo of the Indianapolis. Right.
它是如此精彩，并且从一个场景自然地过渡到另一个关于伤疤的对比。事实上，我对此思考了很多，它之所以被提及，是因为他们在比较伤疤，布罗迪说，你胳膊上那个是什么？那是洗掉“印第安纳波利斯”号纹身的痕迹。没错。
And I think about that all the time. Like, why would he remove it? Yeah. And like, what was going on in his head that he would remove it instead of keep it there? And with every part of his character that you get in other ways, that seems like this extreme moment in his life that you have no knowledge of, but you just have this little tiny peek into. And I love that part of it knowledge of, but you just have this little tiny peek into. And I love that part of it too.
我一直在想这件事。他为什么要把它洗掉呢？是的。还有，他脑子里在想什么，促使他把它洗掉而不是保留它？结合他在其他方面展现出的性格，这似乎是他生命中一个极端时刻，你对此一无所知，却只能窥见极其微小的一角。我也很喜欢这一部分。
It's just, I didn't really thought about that. That is super interesting that he would, and that's like old sailors don't have tattoos removed, you know? Yeah, exactly. So like the level of trauma or whatever he was trying to get away from or whatever it was, like it was clearly something that haunted him in a way like it was not an adventure story to him.
我以前真的没怎么想过这件事。他居然会这么做，这真是超级有趣，老水手是不会洗掉纹身的，你知道的？是的，完全如此。所以这种创伤的程度，或者说他试图逃避的东西，无论那是什么——这显然是一件纠缠着他的事，对他来说，这绝不是一个充满冒险色彩的故事。
Yeah. What happened? And, or maybe it was just something else. Like, you don't really know, it's an incomplete narrative, but I've tried to fill that in my head lots of times. And I never come up with like what I think is the answer, but it mainly has to do with him trying to get away from it and his willingness, his
发生了什么？或者也许只是别的原因。你看，你并不是真的知道，这是一个不完整的叙事，但我已经在脑海中无数次试图填补这个空白。我从来没有得出过我认为是答案的东西，但它主要与他试图逃避过去有关，以及他内心的意愿，他
willingness to talk about it that moment. I think it points to how close he's gotten in this short amount of time, but also that he senses the peril that they're in and wants them to be really aware of what's, you know, what's about to happen and what's about to happen, like happens almost immediately after it's like they start, you know, the shark starts knocking into the boat. Yeah. In the next scene. So yeah, it's funny and I never really thought about it,
在那个时刻想要讲述它的意愿。我认为这表明他在这么短的时间里与他们走得有多近，同时也表明他感觉到了他们所处险境，并希望他们真正意识到即将发生的事情，你知道的，即将发生的事情，就像在事情发生后几乎立刻发生的一样，就像他们开始，你知道的，鲨鱼开始撞击小船。是的。在接下来的场景中。所以，是的，这很有趣，我以前从没真正想过，
but it's almost like Quint knows this is the last time I'm going to tell this story. Here the whole episode with me or any of the other great guests talking lovingly about their favorite movie, go to moviecrush.show or search for it wherever you listen to podcasts. 99% Invisible is Katie Mingle, Sharifusef, Sean Riel, Kurt Colstet, Delaney Hall, Avery Trollman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Taren Mazza, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California
但这几乎就像昆特知道这是我最后一次讲这个故事了。想要收听我和其他优秀嘉宾深情谈论自己最喜爱电影的整集节目，请访问 moviecrush.show 或在您收听播客的任何地方搜索它。99% Invisible 的成员有凯蒂·明格尔、谢里夫·优素福、肖恩·里尔、库尔特·科尔斯特、德兰尼·霍尔、艾弗里·特罗尔曼、埃mett·菲茨杰拉德、塔伦·马扎，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽市中心的 Radio Row。
We are a part of radio topia from PRX a collective of the best most innovative shows in all of podcasting We are supported by the night foundation and listeners just like you You can find 99% invisible and join discussions about the show on Facebook You can tweet at me at Roman Mars on the show at 99PI Orc. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. If you want to see the latest video we made with a box about controversial shared spaces, you have to go to our website. It's 99PI.org.
我们是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的一部分，这是一个汇集了播客界最棒、最具创新性节目的联盟。我们得到了奈特基金会和像您这样的听众的支持。您可以在 Facebook 上找到 99% Invisible 并参与有关该节目的讨论。您可以在 Twitter 上 @我 Roman Mars，或 @节目 99PI。我们也在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上。如果您想观看我们制作的关于有争议共享空间的最新视频，您必须访问我们的网站。网址是 99PI.org。
Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Radiotopia。来自 PRX。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。